live from the lobby of Ramsay Solutions
James and Amy are with us hey guys how
are you hey Dave hi David great welcome
welcome where do you guys live if you
live in Atlanta Georgia
fun welcome to Nashville thank you and
here to do your debt-free scream yes sir
and how much have you paid off a hundred
and thirty six thousand dollars awesome
and how long did that take three years
and eleven months all right very good
and your range of income during that
time it was about seventy-five at the
beginning and up to about a hundred okay
and cool what do you guys do for a
living I'm a stay-at-home mom and I'm an
engineer at Delta Airlines very cool
good that's a lot of dad I mean it took
you four years but I mean that's a lot
of debt almost four years yeah so what
kind of debt it's our home Dave you paid
off your house good for you so what's
this house in Atlanta Georgia worth just
about two hundred Awesomeness how cool
is that hold are you - I'm 31 330 - are
you afraid for house you're so awesome
we've been waiting for you to laugh like
that for so long and you are so young
you're gonna be so rich it's gonna be
unbelievable I mean with no house
payment you're gonna be able to be
generous and give and change your family
tree and build wealth
oh my goodness wow what made you start
on this four years ago so Dave are our
our debt kind of came in two waves the
first started back in 7 mm-hmm we were
engaged and just a few weeks before we
got married we heard you on the radio
mm-hmm and I've read your Total Money
Makeover book right after I heard about
you and the next week I was just on
board I went out and got a second job
working at Home Depot to pay off our
student loans Wow and so we in the next
24 months after we heard about you we
paid off $34,000 Wow and then at that
point we kind of read
calibrated our life and we decided to
move to Atlanta I got it I got a new job
at in in Atlanta and we we sort of reset
for a couple months we rented a house we
send up a fifteen thousand dollar
emergency fund and another fifteen
thousand dollars for a downpayment on
this house so when we bought the house
finally we had kind of a seven-year we
had a 15-year mortgage and a seven-year
plan mm-hmm to pay it off and we kind of
follow that plan for about two years and
about two years in we're on a cruise
we took an anniversary cruise mm-hmm and
we read your book smart money smart kids
from you and Rachel and we just had
started some good conversation we talked
about our family and where we wanted to
lead our family and we just decided that
this mortgage had to go was gonna be the
first thing on the list so we went we
really tighten the belt and we were able
to pay it off instead of fifteen or
seven years in four years less than four
years and I love it $136,000 oh I'm so
proud of you guys way to go thank you
very well done thank you and along the
way you had a couple kids just a few
just a few four to be exact Laurie and
so let's introduce them what are their
names and ages you guys join mom and dad
know your guys what are their names and
ages linden he's seven uh-huh this is
Regan he's five mm-hmm and then Carter
he's three mm-hmm and this is grant he
just turned one okay my four sons yeah
there we go I love it
there's an old TV show when I was a
little kid called my threesome what
congratulations you guys so have these
guys do they know what's going on yes we
we a few a few months ago well last year
we decided to get them involved by
having rocks and we have an equity and a
debt Rock jar and so every payment they
would put the wrong move it from the
debt jar into the equity they can
visually see what mom and dad are up to
we've been talking about so they're
definitely involved and knew what was
going on okay all right very cool well
that's good that's awesome so they've
been practicing from Atlanta their debt
free screen all right we've got a crop
top eeeh Chris Hogan's book so you can
read it retire inspired number one
national bestseller and that's the next
phase is just to continue to build
wealth and man you all will be able to
do that like crazy very well done
all right so if yes sir can I interrupt
I wonder I want to I just want to take a
moment to thank you for your for your
work and pouring out into our lives
every day and thank your team all the
people that are in Financial Peace
University we've we've taught four or
five classes Wow
thank you we've you know your books that
you write I think I've read everything
you've ever written and and all the
people that you recommend so thank you
thank your team and just be encouraged
you guys are doing a really great job
and it's really changing lives
so thank you please forget I forgot to
ask you what was the toughest part of
this for you all the toughest part is
feeding a family a growing family on a
tight budget that's just that's a
challenge period right here and white
all these all these boys or teenagers at
the same time you may end up back in
that could happen but the hardest part
for me was was patience I think our
generation we just want it all now and
we want it immediately we want the house
now and then we want to paid off now I
know we did it fast but I I I still was
impatient about it so that was a
toughest part for me well good job you
guys can get a well done all right James
and Amy Lyndon Reagan Carter grant
hundred thirty six thousand dollars paid
off in three years and eleven months
that's their house baby
seventy-five to a hundred thousand
dollar income count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
Wow now if you're watching on the
YouTube stream or the Dave Ramsey show
app and you're watching this show you're
seeing those four little boys and that
cute family and then you hear that sound
of those kids screaming they're
debt-free you know what that sound is
that's the sound of a family tree being
changed you ever wondered what it
sounded like well that's what it sounds
like because those little guys you
understand that these guys are making
$100,000 a year they don't have a
payment in the world not a payment in
the world you understand what the math
of that is when you're 32 years old
if you save our house payment on a
$200,000 house oh let's just do it why
not just for the fun of it let's just
just so you understand what I mean when
I say a family trees change let's just
say you had a $1,500 house payment yes
for the fun of it
and let's just say you did that from 32
to oh let's say 60 well let's just say
yeah 62 so that'd be like 30 years you
did that and if you put that in a decent
grow stock mutual fund starting from
nothing that would be five million two
hundred thousand dollars that's what you
just heard if they just pay themselves a
house payment and they never get a race
and they never save any other money they
just pay themselves a house payment
that's all they do now you understand
that this family is going to get into
continue to get raises they're going to
continue to manage money well they're
going to continue to fill up their 401ks
in addition to that they're gonna fund
the college fund for those four boys you
know understand they're gonna do other
things to build wealth so you understand
that this is not a five million dollar
discussion that we're having right here
I'm talking to people with fifteen or
twenty million dollars that's what
changes a family tree instead of giving
it all to some stupid bank that has
better furniture than you've got in
calling it a payment that I can
quote-unquote afford they decided to pay
off their house and they did it
they took a 15-year mortgage will pay it
off in seven well let's pay it off in
four drop the Mike baby drop the Mike
this is what
but when you hear those kids screaming
we're debt-free yes they've been
practicing yes their mom and dad have
been talking about it yes they've been
moving a rock from the debt jar to the
equity jar but you understand those kids
have a visual visceral emotional thing
they traveled from Atlanta to Nashville
to mark this moment in their families
lives you were hearing the sound of a
family tree being changed now my
question is
why aren't you next well it's up to you
I'm not gonna do it you got to do it
it's your turn baby step off this is the
Dave Ramsey hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common